prison
nobody that's a leader would not do what
i did
and i know there's a risk there's a
danger but that's okay
[Music]
i just left walter reed medical center
and i learned so much in moroni virus
don't
be afraid of it you're going to beat it
we have the best
medical equipment don't be afraid of it
feel great like better than i have in a
long time
be afraid of it i didn't feel so good
don't be afraid of it you're gonna beat
it we have to put
on a virus don't be afraid of it and now
i'm better
maybe i'm immune i don't know be afraid
of it don't
let it dominate don't let it take over
your life be afraid
of it don't let that happen you're the
greatest country in the world afraid of
it
as your leader i had to do that i knew
there's danger do it but i had to do it
but don't let it dominate your lives get
out there
be careful we have the best medicines in
the world
and it all happened very shortly and
they're all getting approved
and the vaccines are coming momentary
[Music]
virus
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
convalescent flows with strong
antibodies
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
infection convalescence
[Music]
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescence
the virus
convalescent
all right welcome everybody i could play
videos and songs
all night but we actually do have things
to get to and things to discuss
uh i am so glad that we can be together
again tonight
because i have so many things uh
stored here for you guys that i've been
just waiting
uh massive dumps of memes to lay upon
you and by the way speaking of massive
dumps i should mention right up front
we are right now under attack by massive
dumps of rain
snow sleet and wind here at the studio
and so
let's all hope that the worst shouldn't
happen
and that we experience a loss of either
power or internet service
let's hope none of that none of that
happens because we
have so much to talk about so let me
start with all of the things
i have at the ready for you guys today
i have a voicemail from violent trumpus
jimmy from philly left at 4 am this
morning i've not pre-screened it
i can only imagine a 4am voicemail from
jimmy from philly
is absolutely insane so that's on the
table as a possibility
i have a series of three voicemails from
troy york
left today at 5 56 a.m
609 a.m and 6 18 a.m
three in a row each of them the full
three minutes long that our system maxes
out at
i've not pre-screened them that's
something we could potentially play for
you
i have a new exclusive song
from jethro bradley which has
musicalized the flatulence of rudy
giuliani it's like
nothing we've ever played before i mean
there's nothing like
we've ever played before that is like
this so i have all of these different
things for you guys
which which we could start looking at i
see
a lot of beautiful super chats coming in
and um some of them are about trump
clogging white house toilets and that
type of thing
and concerns about kovid there are very
few masks here as you can see
we are in the middle of a 911 a day
um today so far okay today only two
thirds of a 911
yesterday much much closer to 29.77 is
the official 9 11 death toll for the day
of
of course then we invaded a country that
didn't attack us and killed like
200 000 civilians so arguably the 911
death toll
is much more than 2977 but i think you
all understand
um it is absolutely insane what's going
on with the virus and look at these
people
look at this let's just listen briefly
yeah no masks no masks no masks so it's
absolutely and utterly insane so we
looked at the coveted numbers already
this is a rally of some consequence this
is a rally where we are expecting donald
trump
it's in uh in georgia where we have two
senate runoffs on january 5th which will
determine whether democrats or
republicans control the senate
the latest polling the right-wing
trafalgar polling
has loffler up and purdue
down rmg research has
loffler down and purdue down
december 3rd warnock plus seven
awesome plus two on november 18th
loffler plus
four so what does all of this mean i'll
wait
what what is all what do all these
polling numbers mean
what do they mean they mean nothing
they mean not that's exactly right uh
twitch
and uh youtube chat completely
destroying it means absolutely nothing
and uh we all must vote stephen kenneth
destiny bonnell ii
and uh molina destiny bonnell ii
are in georgia right now i believe and
maybe we could
even potentially check in with them
later they're they're doing stuff down
there so we all vote look at these
people no mask
uh it's um it's just it's it's
absolutely insane
um and this is the point here michigan
wifey
checking in with a beautiful super chat
it's not just thinning the herd because
they'll infect others that's exactly
right
studies done about the effect of these
trump
corona rallies on cases and deaths
they lead to both cases and deaths but
very often it's not the people at the
rallies because it is a
virus as we heard during that
introductory song
and you infect people who aren't at the
at the rally so it's absolutely and
completely correct
um okay big thank you to one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven
twelve people i appreciate 12 folks who
just grabbed
twitch subs very much appreciate that
people asking about the phone lines i
will address the phone lines momentarily
but before i do that
big thank you to tyson code who is new
member number 13 today and kyle welch
who is new member number 14.
i am very interested in opening the
phone lines today and i will absolutely
do it if we get to 100 members and
patrons
and we may have to do it a little bit
differently some of the content from our
phone calls
lately has been a little bit too racy
and we're gonna i have a
so we're gonna something we're gonna
have to do about that but just as an
example here's a phone call i recently
received
really edgy content okay take a listen
to this hey david it's me
um i just was wondering if you've ever
reconsidered making an only benz
sorry if i if i've done making an
omelette what no no making it only fans
uh you know
uh gardening season is over and it's
time for you to show us your zucchini
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples than any zooks to be
perfectly frank flippy
that works too yeah uh no but i am on
cameo which i think is like the work
safe only fans right
well that works well thank you and by
the way where does the name
flippy come from oh just an alias online
oh does it have any meaning no does it
relate to like
a floppy disk for example remember those
five and a quarter inchers
oh it's supposed to be like flippy
floppy like a stupid way to call
flip-flops
oh i got it by the way are you cleaning
a violin in the background
i know it birds sorry oh it's bird oh
okay
um all right very good well listen i
really i really appreciate the call
flippy
all right thank you have a good day so
very very strong call and as you can see
that's kind of edgy so we're gonna have
to i would love to take phone calls
and we would do that a little bit later
okay let me just keep things going
a couple of super chats zero percent
chance trump makes this about anyone but
himself yeah this will mostly be about
trump and attacking joe biden
uh keep up the good work david watching
your country with horror from vancouver
island i've heard vancouver island is
beautiful i've never had the pleasure
but i would love to visit
um very very strong super chats coming
in with that which i appreciate
okay real quick let me get you guys
caught up about a few
different things okay there are two new
relatively new memes one is the massive
dumps meme this was what donald trump
said during an interview recently
and what happened if you watched the
election i was called by the biggest
people
saying congratulations political people
congratulations sir you just won the
election it was 10 o'clock and you
looked at the numbers and i'm sure you
felt that way
this election was over and then they did
dumps they call them dumps big massive
dumps
okay so massive dumps then was turned
into this
very strong song by one of our listeners
listen to this
[Music]
it's just perfect
big massive dumps
holy [ __ ]
it's one of the best we've had
[Music]
ambient and atmospheric
[Music]
in michigan and pennsylvania huge dumps
in michigan and pennsylvania huge just a
powerful driving beat
in pennsylvania huge dumps
okay so we had that and we also had this
one a lot of people say
david can you appeal to this one's more
ominous
they call them dumps massive dumps
massive dumps it's art yeah it's
performances
[Music]
okay so that's the massive dumps meme i
am i am going to now
but because it's such a special day and
we're standing by for uh what what we'll
we will all rejoice in it being one of
donald trump's last rallies
okay i am going to release an exclusive
for you guys right now and it is related
to
the rudy giuliani flatulence meme okay i
don't know how many of you guys noticed
but the other night rudy giuliani
punctuated another one of these
delusional so-called voter fraud events
with a number of different uh elements
of flatulence okay take a listen
i will i will ask that he'd be he'd be
disciplined for that
first of all the answer that i gave you
is they didn't bother to interview a
single
witness okay so that was the other night
rudy just continuing to to embarrass
himself
this is a world exclusive i want people
to be prepared
to start dumping twitch subs and dumping
super chats if you like this this is a
world exclusive from j
and that is real people keep saying
there's no way that's real
go to the michigan state legislature
website
and look at the original video it is
real people keep saying david that can't
be real
it's real guys it's real okay listen to
this exclusive
which has musicalized the flatulence
i've never seen anything like this
jethro
deserves a uh he should be teaching he
should be uh running the uh
composition program at berkeley okay on
the basis of this production take a
listen to this
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you
they don't want to know the truth well
you probably know the truth
okay so so there's rudy passing gas
but the content of this was also
disgusting this went on for hours
[Music]
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you
they don't want to know the truth well
you probably know the truth
why don't you look at the registered
voters on there
how many registered voters are on there
[Music]
did you do you even know the answer to
that
zero zero there's zero yes how many
weights
what about what about how what about the
turnout rate
120 i mean turning the flatulence into
the
into into the snare essentially it's
i've never seen anything like it and
people clearly responding very very
strongly to it
uh general matsu has just gifted 10 subs
on twitch and people very very
aggressive
uh over on youtube um david's sending
five dollars for that one and daniel
krieger
sending two i mean people are just
exploding from that
it is unbelievable it's one of the
funniest things it's
it's just i've i've never seen anything
like that
um unbelievable unbelievable event
big thank you to gerald flurry uh as
well as
michael mcdonald who are new members 15
and 16
today uh very very much appreciate that
and when
with those additional 11 subs via twitch
that puts us at 27. okay what do you
guys want next
do you want um a very very
dark message that i have to present to
you
or do you want to hear the middle of the
night jimmy from philly
voicemail i have both available right
now
um you know phone calls would be later
people asking for
phone calls would be after the rally
depending on how things go
we'll do the jimmy okay all right so
here's the setup this is a voicemail
from a
a man i was gonna say a gentleman but
that would be a lie from a man named
jimmy from philly he was recently
actually arrested
for i think it was actually uh
i think he i i don't want to misspeak
but i think he was arrested recently
for literally chasing a car full of
black youth
down the street where he lives it's
completely nuts
that i'm not even exaggerating about
that he left a voicemail
at 4 57 a.m this morning
i've not listened to this let's listen
to it together
and and see what it what it's about
david jimmy from philly
i'm sick and [ __ ] tired and listen to
your [ __ ]
about unhinged trump supporters and this
and that oh oh that is just
how that is just perfect jimmy calling
at 4 57 a.m
to yell at me is upset i'm talking about
unhinged trump supporters can you
imagine
why don't you and i have a little debate
on what's really happening you can't you
you you you can't withstand it david
withstand
yourself full of [ __ ] so obviously
deceitful
you make me sick david
i i got my hat's off to you that you can
[ __ ]
over a million people it's almost 1.2
million plus
you know 66k on twitch and then we got
130k on facebook jimmy you got to give
me the right numbers
these people don't even he's got to be
wasted i
i i agree with you guys much anything
you say
they don't refuse it at all so you can
basically
when you get that kind of feedback or
non-feedback or whatever
if i mean i can't imagine he's up for
work at 457. i assume he's still awake
at 4 57 from a night of drinking
you can [ __ ] basically dictate
whatever the [ __ ] you want
congratulations i don't even know what
this voicemail's about honestly
that in itself is a feat you are the
the 2020 winner of deceit
did he say the feat or deceit
yeah my information [ __ ]
[ __ ] your cappuccino oh that's brilliant
oh an anti-cappuccino message popping in
at the end there okay so there is jimmy
from philly
um that is crazy that is really really
crazy stuff
um goddamn user pointing out via super
chat that the
rudy star witness was convicted with
harassment recently yeah and i think she
also released sex
tapes melissa carone released sex tapes
of her and her uh ex-boyfriend or
something like that
a big thank you to judah bulls weber
um as well as christopher routh
who is new member number 29 today all
right listen let me just get this out of
the way
uh oh oh i'm sorry no hold on i have
another um
i have another cup so this is three
voicemails in a row in the middle of the
night from troy york
troy york is another regular caller
let's listen together i've not
pre-screened these yes you may think
that the 48-minute
trump speech was delusional and unhinged
that's true that that 48-minute speech
trump did
was delusional and unhinged so many
other people would it disagree
yes those people also think trump won
the election you just are fearful of the
fact that you know that this has been an
election fought
and then trump will get the word out and
more and more people are
questioning the legitimacy of this
president
that's actually untrue over time the
number of people who think trump won has
gone down like right after when trump
first did his voter fraud massive dumps
um
86 of his voters thought he really won
and then last week it was down to 80
percent
and then and then i would assume by next
week it would be more in the 70s so
troy's wrong
so that's one voicemail he maxed out the
full three minutes that was at 5 56 a.m
this morning
and actually based on troy is in central
times once troy accidentally doxed
himself when he called in so we know
exactly who troy is and where he is
he's in central time zone so then he
sent he sends a second voicemail minutes
later
and the fact is that you haven't
accepted the truth
and you know that there is election from
so you may say that so he did another
two two minutes and 59 seconds maxed out
the recording again
and then nine minutes later well it took
him three minutes to record it so six
minutes later
he calls back again then the fact that
uh many people have questioned
and uh pretty much
been outspoken against what is obvious
election fraud
tommy solomire i don't know who tommy
sotomayor is
uh anthony brian logan haven't heard of
him
jessie lee peterson that now jessie lee
i've heard of but i don't typically hear
people citing jessie lee as
who you go to as a voice of reason uh
the hodge twins
i don't know who the hodge twins is and
uh
even tyrone magnus had put out youtube
videos
i don't know who tyrone magnus is either
i don't know who any of those people are
hey jack quantum thanks for gifting 10
subs on twitch i
i really do appreciate that thanks very
much so there's three more
voicemails from um from troy york
and then uh did i have anything else
no i guess that's it as far as
voicemails go
so that's that um yeah so it's been
it's all been it's all been pretty wild
one other little thing for you guys
rex chapman the former nba basketball
player
he gave us a very strong follow the
other day and he
tweeted about an hour ago this is video
of my pillow guy
mike lindell at this rally we're about
to watch
saying something about arrests or
incoming let's take a listen to that
how do you not put people in prison but
the most you know they will be going to
prison
but in the meantime december 14th is so
important
we have to get this governor in here
governor kemp frank kemp has to
give an order to get to have a meet to
have a
congress meeting or whatever they do
they're legislated yeah he doesn't know
what it is but someone's got to meet to
give the election to trump
and pull georgia down and don't give it
to mine yeah and at this point it
doesn't matter remember even without
georgia biden's got what is it 290
without georgia georgia
i think is 16. doesn't matter who they
give it to don't you don't give it to
mine just
and find out all your corruption find
out the corruption and don't give it to
biden
because if you pull down georgia
pennsylvania and crooked nevada
oh okay well now you're saying take
three states from biden
now nobody has 270 and then it goes to
the december 14th vote
and donald trump wins the election he
doesn't seem to understand that the
december 4
if you pull down states and they don't
vote they don't vote on december 14th
like
has anyone ever seen less of an
understanding of the process
while insisting they know exactly how to
flip an election
it's like these people a guy who makes
pillows
doesn't even understand what happens on
december 14th
and is being interviewed as a voice of
expertise
on how to steal an election from joe
biden who got more votes than anybody
has ever gotten in history
it's and and they see this guy as an
authority of some kind it's absolutely
insane
uh okay daniel says david if you hired
someone from craigslist
to remove a certain legume from your
teeth but they became out of control
would you tell the mental dental rental
to be gentle removing the lentil
uh yes yes fiona says laughing my ass
off in the uk
rudy is like an unhinged sweaty clown
thanks for working so hard to keep us
all
entertained yeah the rudy stuff is
completely out of control it's it's
crazy
um i also want to say thanks uh to
justin smith who is new member
number 40 at joinpackman.com okay listen
here
here's the the sort of dark ominous
thing that i have to tell you guys about
um we have been experiencing
massive dumps of memberships okay
and i have just two exam i told you on
wednesday that we're getting a lot of
emails from people saying
david i'm sorry i got to cancel my
membership because of covid
and a couple people said show us some of
those emails so i have a couple of those
emails
to show you here um here is one
okay let me see if i can zoom this i
need to get proper zoom for you guys and
this this is just horrible that this is
going on
this is alex who said yesterday good
evening mr pakman
it's unfor so formal it's unfortunate
but i have ended my membership because i
have been unemployed since march and my
family and i are unsure when will feel
that it's safe for me to be in a
real-life workplace again i will remain
subscribed to the youtube channel
i'm sorry says alex and then this one is
from rachel
and this is just horrible hello my name
is rachel i
i uh whited out you know rachel's last
name i would like to cancel my
membership i'm having financial
difficulties and can't spare the expense
of a long-term
subscription she gives me personal info
here which i've white it out
uh thank you for understanding and i'm
sorry about cancelling my membership so
this is hitting a lot of people a lot a
lot of people
and and i get it which is why uh you
know we so appreciate the people that
have been able
to sign up in the in the last week or so
um and it it really does mean a lot and
we've got a lot planned for 2021.
so my pitch to you is if you can spare a
dollar 80 a month
grab one of those memberships at
joinpakman.com we keep all but two
percent of every payment
we just pay two percent to process to
swipe credit cards
um and that coupon code fresh start
beautiful coupon and in fact
close to an illegal coupon code i don't
know if you guys know
but i was reported by producer pat for
these coupon codes remember this this
was crazy
hello yes i would like to report voter
fraud today
sure what's your experience well there's
a certain david parkman who i know
to have voted in nevada um
three times at least
okay and what county is that in clark
county
he goes there uh twice a year for a um
conference and also he happens to be
giving out um
borderline illegal membership discounts
right uh
like 50 off 60 off 70 off
and i'm worried that that could be
sacrificing the integrity of the
election
okay and what was your name my name is
mcdonald okay so the point
is we the the these membership discounts
70
off we've been reported and i don't
think that they're gonna last into joe
biden's presidency so the the important
thing is
uh we this is the time to take advantage
of it
um joinpakman.com use the coupon code
don't use the coupon code it's
completely up to you
but we do have massive massive
membership dumps happening so we
appreciate everybody who's been able to
sign up
we are standing by for donald trump in
georgia campaigning and
presumably will be shot out of a cannon
uh oh
i'm sorry people are saying they signed
up and i didn't thank them
braden mccall signed up liam
mcintyre zachary schulke
has signed up as well as lowly
valencia which puts us at 44
a perfect number and also thanks to
a bearded austrian and a couple of other
people on twitch
that puts us at 48 and yes thinking of
opening phone lines
after the rally absolutely we will talk
about that a little bit later
rusty says the massive dumps of
memberships should be offset by the use
of your bigly illegal
fresh start coupon code consider
changing it to fresh
chart yeah would more people sign up if
the coupon code was fresh
shart instead of fresh start because
i'll change it right now you know
i'll set the coupon code to whatever you
want uh as long as
long as people are using it um we are
just uh we are exactly 30
wait hold on 30 31 days i guess
from the january 5th runoff elections in
georgia
donald trump here in the small plane we
will be hearing from him momentarily
i'm guessing he's going to suggest
voting for the two republicans
although there's now a republican
movement saying boycott the georgia
election
because it's rigged now many of you we
talked about this on the bonus show the
other day
um you all know that one of the things
i've been pushing for
for a decade on this program is
vote we want more people voting i want
high engagement the more people vote the
more invested people are and what goes
on
and the better i believe it is for the
progressive movement now
i would never ever ever contradict that
by saying
hey republicans stay home i would never
do that that would be antithetical to
everything i've advocated on this
program
but if republicans are going to say
let's boycott the election in georgia
i'm not going to argue with them if that
if their strategy is
boycott the election in georgia go the
hell ahead
i won't be advocating for it but i'm not
going to argue with anybody
and of course um you know joe biden
being able to get
big things done depends on those two
elections if they are one
then democrats would have 50 and
on 50 50 ties kamala harris would become
the deciding vote so i believe everybody
should vote
if republicans are determined to boycott
this election to make a political
statement
have at it hoss i'm not going to get in
the way a tyler says this one
is for rachel david and team
thanks keep up the great work thanks
tyler i appreciate that
new coupon code rudy's duty
uh morgan says what's the best response
to fiscally conservative folks who say
where are they going to get the money
for more stimulus checks we have the
money
we have the money um
a retro says i'm withdrawn from brandeis
after me and others identified white
powerists and anti-semites
brandeis lawyers gave me a warning i
don't know what that's about i'm sorry
chakaseki says vote in georgia in to
pinch
off the massive loffler and flush the
purdue
beautiful uh beautiful uh i like that
that's good chakaseki
very nice david is trump starting his
2024 campaign rally
i actually am wondering if tonight trump
will say something like and if it
doesn't work out
i'll see you back in four years i think
it's certainly conceivable he might uh
say something like that tonight i do
think that that's possible
um oh my goodness we just received
a huge dump of memberships
i'm gonna have to thank some folks hold
on charles
erico brad brown morgan
fisher blake convoy
gavin ir jake sorenson
matthew michael sash daniels
ruth garcia sarah gutierrez
wow this is insane what's going on uh i
don't want to take up the new uh
the the the entire rest of the stream
naming people so let me just get a total
number
uh okay oh so it's plus 22 that puts us
at 60.
wow that's a strong number i did not
expect
um i did not expect that that's that's
wild
catherine says greetings from ecuador
keep up the good work appreciate that
i have never been to ecuador would love
to go
by the way that reminds me i saw someone
ask if i'm reading any anything
interesting
anything new that's interesting i am
reading this book i believe it's called
it's called like 432 days or 428 days
436 days it's about the a salvadorian
fisherman salvador alvarenga who
went to mexico drifted offshore in a
storm
and spent more than 400 days at sea
before ultimately being rescued it's an
unbelievable read i'm gonna get the book
done in like three days because it's so
compelling i can't put
it down um really really great book i
would encourage you to
check that out a lot of you noticing
that there's a
dearth of masks yes there is a dearth of
masks
it's insane completely and utterly
insane
exile king covid 45 to epstein
island for his new reality show papi
owned bigly
okay adidia
um oh oh i see oh i'm sorry people are
asking about my math
so yeah that it would that was not the
full number i i
i was doing different math than what i
was speaking i apologize for that
uh but what i do now have is plus eight
from where we were which puts us now at
68.
438 days is the book i'm referring to
thank you appreciate that
uh melee max
in the chat helping me out with the name
of the book
excellent book excellent book jesus
himself could come down from heaven and
say trump lost and there was no fraud
and the maga hats would call him a
liberal chill more or less yeah
more or less kate says keep up the great
info
um thanks to jeff in boston for gifting
five subs which along with two other
people
puts us at 75. oh if people are just
joining yeah i'll replay it so i don't
know how many of you guys know this but
uh the other day rudy giuliani um he
farted at least four times during a
hearing and it's like okay it's a bodily
function but it's just sort of like the
most poetic punctuation for this
just a reminder of that i will i will
ask that he'd be he'd be disciplined for
that
first of all the answer that i gave you
is they didn't bother to interview a
single
witness so anyway um jethro bradley
debuted and he saw an interview where he
takes the fart and he turns it into the
back beat it's it's genius
single witness just like you they don't
want to know the truth
well you probably know the truth okay so
so there's rudy passing gas
but the content of this was also
disgusting this went on for hours
genius there's rudy passing gas
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you
they don't want to know the truth well
you probably know the truth
then we get to melissa carone
[Music]
i'd say that pole book is off by over a
hundred thousand
[Music]
yes how many weights what about what
about how what about
the turnout rate 120
witness beautiful absolutely perfect
track
uh so anyway so that's that that's just
jethro bradley
and a very very explosive uh song
literally and figuratively i guess is is
what i would say
uh we did just get a plus 18 on the
website memberships
which correct my math if i'm wrong puts
us at 93.
my math now is functioning a little bit
a little bit better
question from australia to participate
in voting in the runoffs did you have to
vote in the federal election
no and very importantly james if you are
going to be 18
by january 5th even if you are 17 today
to the 17 year olds in georgia pay very
close attention
if you are 17 and 11 months old right
now because we've got a month
until the runoffs you can register to
vote
on january 5th very very very important
here's an interesting question for you
guys with the moderators we've been
having
a debate a little bit about when people
show up like for example a user named
it'll buff
out just said trump won in a landslide
is that should we ban people for that
because i've always said
it's we welcome conservatives
libertarians everybody's welcome to chat
and participate
but when you're deliberately saying
things that are
you you know they they get flagged on
twitter if people show up and say trump
actually won
should we ban for that not yet people
are saying
okay that's fair oh i see some people
are saying if
once joe biden is sworn in
and if people keep showing up and saying
it then we should ban them
oh now now more people are saying yes
okay well that's interesting yeah i mean
it doesn't really bother me
i don't care about it but we've been
having it like for example if people
spam
trump 2020 when he lost in the chat it's
like the 2020 election's over
should trump 2020 be at least should we
at least delete
those messages not ban the people but
delete the trump 2020 messages
guys it's not about freedom of speech
this is a twitch and youtube channel
delete the message but don't ban oh
that's an interesting perspective
yeah okay so basically i'm seeing every
different opinion
i guess we'd have to put it to a uh to a
poll julian asks if i'd have if i've had
polish food before do i like pierogi
yes i like pierogi um i'm not big on the
uh
i'm not big on the stuffed stuffed
cabbage
but and i don't i don't eat pork anymore
so
some of those sausages are uh you know
the sausage from the standpoint of
sausage is not going so well
i'm being told that the david pakman
show website is down no it seems to be
working fine
just tried it maybe it went down just
very very briefly
but there's not even that many people on
on the website the website is
beautifully working
and we in fact just had seven more
sign ups which puts us at 100. so listen
i will open phone lines because we got
to 100
but let's just see if we can get to 306
which was biden's electoral votes
i do want to also add uh
seven on twitch we're counting twitch as
well
it all counts today my friends it all
counts i will open phone lines and i
look forward to hearing from people
as we stand by for donald trump
dwayne says publicly humiliate the
trumpers
rusty mentioning the bad gateway yeah
but no it seems to be working fine
what happened to kraken is it loose in
georgia yeah
uh actually hold on a second i have
video of when they released the kraken
here's rudy releasing the kraken
i will ask that he'd be he'd be
disciplined for that
hear that the answer that i gave you is
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness that was the kraken being
released and it didn't overturn a single
state
shockingly uh okay it looks like donald
trump as
with a with a uh consortium of people
many not wearing masks are walking over
let's take a quick listen
[Music]
oh they're still going with that song
god that makes me sick listen if you are
just joining uh we are here for what
will hopefully be one of donald trump's
last rallies ever
if you are watching on youtube there's
32 000 of you
please hit that subscribe button it's so
important we are trying to get to 1.2
million subscribers on youtube before
the end of the year
it's free to subscribe and last stream
you guys broke the subscribe button
where youtube thought
it must be spam because there couldn't
possibly be this number of people
signing up uh so make sure to do that
and of course if you're watching on
twitch
we are exactly two-thirds of the way to
a hundred our first hundred thousand
subscribe followers on twitch and i
would love it if you uh make sure to
follow us there as well
the the bitchkin chicken says david do
you have chickens you know i don't have
chickens but
now i am a huge egg snob
is that melania oh it is i'm a huge egg
snob now where after a friend of mine
gave me some of his grass-fed backyard
eggs and that yolk was like a neon
orange from all the beta-carotene in the
grass
the other day i went and got like you
know organic eggs and i scrambled it and
it was like white
compared to these orange yolks i i am a
complete egg snob so tomorrow this is
breaking
i'm gonna be going to a farm tomorrow
and
uh getting a dozen very very powerful
yolked eggs
and um yeah it did so i'm not i don't
have chickens but i would i would love
uh to be able to get eggs yeah
from the lakes of minnesota okay so it's
still going
we um i don't know what we're gonna hear
from trump in this one i don't know if
melania will be introducing him or what
it's just it's a complete and total mess
it's a complete and total mess
oh people are talking about they they
like the uh backyard eggs as well yeah
yeah i mean it just would be complicated
to do normally i'm traveling a lot so
it's hard to
my friend who has eggs like each day he
has to kind of like close the door in
the coop it's crazy
okay we've got another eight folks who
just signed up
on my website and another four
on twitch which puts us at 119 very very
strong number
uh we are going to be shortly hearing
from donald trump really appreciate
everybody who's here
i don't know what to expect but uh
let's see it might be melania first
let's see hopefully trump will dance too
[Music]
and it does seem as though melania will
be delivering a statement about being
best
and all of that stuff as you can see we
have a global pandemic that is ravaging
right now and i
see very few masks here people literally
shoulder to shoulder
donald trump giving us that pump and
much like arnold
clearly trump addicted to the pump as we
can see
trump's hair looking green today which
is unusual could be a white balance
issue nope it's like that on all of
these
uh all right i'm guessing melania will
speak it is wonderful
to be here with you tonight thank you
for coming
out and supporting us president trump
continues to fight for you every single
day
fight for you to die
do not let your voices be silenced
hey guys you voted and lost that's it in
the senate
it is more important than ever that your
exercise your right as an american
citizen and vote
[Applause]
under my husband's leadership our
borders are safer
global terrorists have been destroyed
and historic peace deals in the middle
east have been made
our nation is is respected again and
our allies are now doing their fair
share globally
yeah president trump has backed
the american people
and opportunities for women have
expanded in our workforce our economy
has soared and unemployment has shrunk
no unemployment's higher than when he
took office when a global pandemic
hit the united states last january my
husband
put the american peoples first
what and now under this administration
and because of our amazing medical
capabilities
and resources we are closer than ever
to vaccinate that will save millions of
lives
is is she have i mean listen i know she
doesn't speak english as a first
language
do you think that it's written
incorrectly or that she's saying
the stuff wrong and i think she just
blinked morse code for hostage
lesler and senator perdue
[Applause]
thank you and god bless you and your
families
it is now my pleasure to welcome the
president united states
donald j trump very strange event so far
would be funny to see trump shake her
hand i mean could it be less personal
now he's pushing her off man
thank you so much off the stage please
oh i didn't realize how funny the chance
of four more years would be given the
absurdity of the loss i actually i
actually
forgot popular first lady
[Applause]
thank you very much and thank you
melania and i want to say
hello georgia now she's back on the
stage great job
you know we won georgia just so you
understand he kicked her off and now
she's back
and we won florida and we won a lot of
places
thank you thank you thank you very much
thank you isn't this the best
i mean it's completely corrosive to
democracy but the the copium is
is strong well thank you very much
thank you no we want a lot of places we
want florida we want ohio big big we
want them big remember we were going to
lose florida they said
we were five down in florida we won by a
lot he's acting like he won the election
down in ohio and we won by a lot
[Applause]
[Music]
i think they say that if you win florida
and if you win ohio in history you've
never lost an election
he set a record he was the first guy you
were right
we've never lost an election we're
winning this election
[Laughter]
this is the best
and i will say we're uh fighting very
hard for this state when you look at all
of the corruption and all of the
problems having to do with this election
yes we're corrupt here and then i wait
for the numbers
but when the numbers come out of
ceilings and come out of leather bags
uh you start to say what's going on but
i want to just tell you that
those are lies i love this state i love
the people in the state and i'm thrilled
to be back
in magnificent georgia
with thousands of proud hard-working
americans
it's a mind virus he says they won the
crowd cheers like he won and he'll be
gone in seven weeks
we started five years ago and i said
you're going to be saying christmas
again and we say it proudly again
although they'll they'll be trying to
take that word again out of the
vocabulary we're not going to let them
do that
i also want to express our profound
condolences to the family of
harrison deal a young and brilliant
campaign staffer for
senator leffler who tragically died in a
terrible car accident yesterday you know
about it he was
an incredible magnificent young man and
i just want to say our
prayers are with his friends and loved
ones and we will keep his memory in our
hearts and he's looking down right now
and he's
very proud of kelly and david he's very
proud of all of us so i just want to
express he's proud of trump too how does
he know that family and everybody thank
you thank you kevin
and let me also express our warmest best
wishes and love to all of those people
and families suffering from the
covet pandemic vaccines are on their way
yeah like many of the people at the
rally will soon be suffering take
another administration
five years it took us seven months
and they're starting next week and we're
gonna start if getting vaccines depended
on trump
why does britain also have one that they
developed at oxford that had nothing to
do with trump at the same time
immune i hope it's true
you know they say that before i had it
they said if you catch it you're immune
for life once i got it they said if you
catch it you're immune for four months
right you know
but they're on their way the vaccines
and they're great vaccines and safe
and brilliant actually to think of it
what we've done in such a short period
of time nobody thought
they call it even some of the enemies
call it a medical miracle what we've
done
the enemies call it a miracle and
they're already here
and i can testify to that fact i'll tell
you what some
incredible work has been done over the
last seven months
trump's testimony just get credit for
that don't let anyone ever take it away
from us
[Applause]
we're gathered here tonight to ensure
a very important word ensure
because these are two great great people
that i know so well
and respected by everybody in washington
and beyond
that david perdue and kelly lefler
win the most important congressional
runoff probably in american history i
really believe that i think it's an
american
trump already lost the most important
election in american history now it's up
to the senate
at least you have two beauties and you
know what you also have two beauties
running against them but beauty in a
different way
they're two beauties but there's never
been a
case where a state has had this
prominence on
senate races because they're never
together
and this is something that's very
important and you have to get out you
have to vote you have to make sure you
have every vote counted
yes everybody has to count you got to
make sure they don't throw away any
ballots
you got to make sure that when they
collect the ballots and they start
bragging about how many ballots they
already have you got to make sure your
secretary of state knows what the hell
he's doing there he goes
going after brad raffensberger make sure
your governor gets a lot tougher than
he's been he's got to get a lot tougher
and going after the governor as well
because at stake in this election
is control of the u.s senate and that
really means control of this country
the voters of georgia will determine
which party runs
every committee writes every piece of
legislation
controls every single taxpayer dollar
very simply you will decide whether your
children will grow up in a socialist
country or whether they will grow up in
a free country and
and under joe biden who are the
socialists again
beginning for these people these people
want to go
further than socialism into a
communistic
form of government yes joe biden wants
the government rationing potatoes
somehow that doesn't suit georgia too
well that's not
that that doesn't work too well i think
kelly in georgia does it huh
david and kelly are running against
radical john ossoff
and rafael warnock
really radical ossoff and warnock are
the two
most extreme far left liberal senate
candidates in the history of our country
[Laughter]
bernie is to both of their left and he's
a senator right now what is he talking
about
you must go vote and vote they wouldn't
even be the most liberal senators
you have to do it they cheated and they
rigged our presidential election
but we will still win it we will still
win it
we'll still win it and they're going to
try and rig this election too
[Applause]
what are they saying stop the steal or
four more years
now we're uh we continue to fight we've
had some
great moments we just need somebody with
courage to do what they have to do
because everyone knows it's wrong right
we need somebody with courage somebody
that makes decisions
and we'll be going up to the supreme
court very shortly and we really if we
have
unclear that anything's going to get to
the supreme court they've got nine days
if we have courage and wisdom
i think you know what the answer is
going to be because you can't let people
get away with what they got away with
with over
uh-oh think of it with over the language
is getting dicey
votes over think of that more than
i got more votes than any sitting
president in history 11 million more
votes
and still lost by 6 million that we got
in 2016.
and we thought that if we could get 68
million 67 million that would be the end
all of our great brilliant
geniuses said uh you'd win if you get 67
or 68
yes they weren't that smart 74 million
plus
and they're trying to convince us that
we lost we didn't lose
[Applause]
they found a lot of well the next four
years are going to be insane
they got rid of some too the 74 let me
tell you the 74 could have been even
higher
as the great pollster john mclaughlin
who's really
a great pulser one of the most highly
respected
he said there's no way this could have
happened other than the obvious cheating
or a rigged election there's no way it
could have happened
you know it's uh it's interesting i
wrote this out
and i had just a few of the facts which
i think because i want to get onto the
presidentials
i want to i want to stay on presidential
but i got to get to these two because
they're incredible
but listen this is amazing the facts
and each fact is like
irrefutable let's see it means win
president trump received done by one of
the most brilliant
political people president trump
received more votes than any previous
incumbent president in history
but biden got more but biden got more
we received more votes than anybody in
history any incumbent in history
we lost supposedly we didn't but biden
got more we're gonna you're gonna see
that
no incumbent who received 75 of the
total primary vote
lost reelection in the history of our
country there was no primary
in the republican party it's shocking
trump didn't get 98
there was no republican primary of
course he got 75 percent
is the only one of five incumbents since
1912
to receive more than 90 percent of the
primary vote
and again anybody received over 75
percent they won
there was no primary 84 you guys
remember there was nobody running
against trump other than in a few states
and they cancelled a bunch of primaries
because of the pandemic
ever and nobody that's received
all of the primary votes nobody's
received at a much lesser
level he's almost bragging that it's
amazing how he lost like it's
embarrassing how he lost
it's rigged it's a fixed deal nationally
initially show that 26 percent of
president trump's voting chair
came from non-white voters the highest
presidential
irrelevance
since 1960 that's a long time ago
president trump would think of this one
president trump won
18 of 19 bellwether counties you know to
bellwether county it's a big deal
it turns out it doesn't matter 19 a
record
never happened that between 1980
and 2016 voted for the eventual
president in every single election and
before that it was almost every election
let me interpret our party was
marginally less racist
race racially divided than before and
yet i still managed to lose by seven
million
biden did not demonstrate coattails for
the down ballot races had no coattails
i'm shocked to hear that
in fact he got 80 million votes but when
he made a thanksgiving day speech on the
internet
oh no they say he had less than a
thousand people how do you have
a million votes and you have a thousand
check out my video clip about that three
million votes and you have less than a
thousand people
[Music]
with republicans maintaining control so
here's what happened
so biden didn't demonstrate coattails
down ballot races
but with republicans maintaining control
first time this has ever happened
control of the senate winning all 27
toss-up races in the house
kevin mccarthy great job mitch great job
winning all 27 toss-up races and now
think of it
we didn't lose a seat in the house think
of this first time
that anybody i think in history we
didn't lose one seat normally you lose
two
three five and you replace we lost
nobody sitting in congress
out of his mind with kevin mccarthy
not losing a single legislative chamber
and making big gains at the state level
and holding on to the senate i mean look
at what's happened we better
so the message is given everything i'm
saying i am an
extra big loser for still having managed
how to lose
close to losing but they say we lost the
only way is they stuffed the ballot
boxes
president trump won
president trump won as we said both in
florida
and in ohio no fraud there guys by the
way won by a lot
remember you know remember remember the
fake polls where they said he's down by
four
in florida in a one by lot he's down by
two in ohio and we won i think we got
eight or nine or something
up no but nobody's ever done that those
two very powerful big
important states and the beauty is that
we also won georgia
and that was cool and we won south
carolina
it's also daytime right now we're not
going to win in iowa this
trump's also black i mean everything's
backwards right well we won in iowa by
a lot we won in iowa by close to record
numbers i think i have the record
and we won all over the place and many
of these swing states you know it's very
interesting statistic
president obama beat biden all over the
country
except in some of the swing states where
biden beat him badly
how does that work and it they say it's
statistically
impossible he beat crooked hillary
think of this he beat crooked hillary in
the swing states but she beat him
everywhere else
let me tell you this election was rigged
and we can't let it happen
to two of the greatest most respected
people in washington we can't let it
happen again
this is crazy completely corrosive to
democracy
arguably stochastic terrorism
can't let it happen can't let it happen
[Applause]
your governor could stop it very easily
but he's a loser right he's a loser too
hundreds of thousands of illegal votes
were cast in each state
this is very dangerous it's not an
exaggeration to say this is dangerous
tens of thousands more than we needed
were cast in every state we're talking
about not only here but michigan
pennsylvania
how about pennsylvania where they throw
the poll watchers out they threw them
out
they literally threw them out
and they did it here too by the way
right
but we caught them cold no problems in
the states trump trump won
notice i've been able to find the people
with the courage to do the right thing
and that is true in georgia certainly
but we're going to hit those people and
they're going to go down in history
as great people they're going to go down
because we're going to hit him
what does that mean we're going to talk
about the presidential election
a little bit later because we have a big
senatorial race going on in georgia
and we are watching democrats very very
closely and remember this
we had this massive race all over the
country who what does trump mean
what does it even mean we're going to
hit these people like they should
and you know again all i can do is say
i'm running
win and then do a good job as president
that's all i don't run the elections
i don't run to see if people are walking
in with suitcases
and putting them under a table with a
bomb he can't get away from it he can't
get away from it
that story has been debunked government
here
and for whatever reason your secretary
of state and your governor
are afraid of stacey abrams they're
afraid of
so we know the democrats are planning to
cheat
and we can't let them do it again and
we're going to pull ours out one way the
other
but we have to be vigilant because i
don't want these two to work like i
you know i thought we're going to easily
win and that maybe for the first time in
a long time
i'd go take a nice little vacation for
about two days
and then we go back and instead i
probably worked harder in the last three
weeks than i've ever worked in my life
worked he didn't do any work those last
he hasn't done work in months
and i've become friendly with
legislators that i didn't know
four weeks ago and actually they're
great people
actually in my pocket right here you
have a couple of them right in here
whisper jones where's bertrand first
bird well you're a young guy i thought
you were young but not that young
bert jones i want to thank you bird for
being here some of these people were
actually not terrible to be around
for trump thank you very much burn i
appreciate everything you're doing and
so does this big crowd
and this is a big is a lot of people
also brandon beach
senator brandon beach brandon thank you
for everything
we appreciate it william liggins william
he it it's it's i've never seen any it's
like he's like showing up like he won
he's he's acting like he's going to be
president and then he'll be gone
and then what will the people say
where's greg greg
thank you very much greg we appreciate
it
really do we appreciate it great people
and we said uh have this brought back
into your
legislature governor have it brought
back let these people make it
keep it open keeping transparent what he
means is just send different electors
even though biden won
they keep counting the same votes i said
don't count votes
look at the signature you're gonna find
the signatures aren't what they were two
years ago four years ago six years ago
but our two great senate opponents and
these are two people that what did he
say
senator senator pump what was that that
was weird
but one of the people that you're
fighting
i went against him assaf four years ago
he was against a very fine woman karen
he was a great woman and he was leading
by quite a bit and we ended up beating
him
he didn't even live in the district he
was running for congress he didn't even
live in the district
so uh we're going to have the same thing
but ossoff and warnock
will be total pawns of chuck schumer cry
and chuck i only see him cry when the
cameras are wrong
but he said he did say this maybe i'm
hurting you when i
he did say this if we get in we're going
to absolutely make donald trump's life
miserable
can you believe that that's chuck
schumer he made the statement
we're going to investigate him oh those
investigations will go on
and on well they've been investigating
me since the day we came down on the
escalator which
what turned out to be our great first
lady we came down the escalator
he's living in 2015 still lots of other
things but
nancy pelosi aoc
bernie sanders it's hilarious to just
name aoc completely
he just says aoc
i'd rather infamously first we take
georgia then we take america but they
don't mean take america like in a good
sense
no they mean bring it over to things
that the people of georgia don't want
you're not going to like it when they
want to take over your farm gee we own
this farm too you know we were here also
we owned this farm
here's exactly how they will change
america
forever the radical democrats if they
get power
they will immediately abolish the senate
filibuster allowing them to pass
any bill they want and giving them free
reign it actually doesn't seem
like dems would do that wing agenda ever
conceived
while at the same time destroying our
military through a lack of funding
that's all lies yeah that'll never
happen and by the way tell our senators
end section 2 30.
if section 230 is ended trump gets
banned from twitter that day
i want it in the defense bill put it in
because we talked about it recently
security problem
it's a big national security so
hopefully mitch and the senators will
put it in
but it's the one chance we have to bring
big tech who are vicious and violent and
untruthful
to bring big tech if people remind me
later i can talk about 230 about section
230.
so hopefully we will do and it happens
to be a politically very popular thing
to do
by the way if these people get
control their draconian military cuts
will devastate
fort benning fort gordon and the
military families all across no they
won't
we would also like to save the names of
the forts if you don't mind everybody
if there were a reduction to the
military the first thing we would do is
maybe like we only need 40 bases in
germany instead of 50.
fort benning is going to be fine guys
past
warriors heroes in some cases many cases
some turned out to be
heroes in disguise perhaps but they want
to take the names off and they have the
right to desecrate to take down to
destroy to demolish
places in our national parks that we
don't want to demolish
so we have to be very careful of that we
can't let that happen put it
they want to put it in our military bill
of all people elizabeth warren puts that
clause in the military bill
they will impose total open borders so
that people can pour into our country
they and they will give them free health
care free welfare and the right to
vote in your elections you won't ever
win well only citizens can vote
as a republican they even want to take
down the wall you know the wall i want
on the wall too
the wall he never built is coming right
down we will take down the world you
know we have the strongest border we've
ever had now we're almost
finished it's like a campaign it's
stunning that
this speech is no different than two
weeks before it's the same speech as
before the campaign
incredible the effect it's having we
built it despite
rather rather everybody said no chance i
mean we had a whole very powerful
democrat party
opposed me and yesterday i don't know if
you saw it the court
just ruled that the money i took was
taken legally so at least we have a
legal wall
oh okay the appeals court
so we took in and we built the wall and
we'll be finished with it
it's funny this is a senate rally he
still hasn't even talked about them
coming into the country and by the way
we want people to come into our country
you see that by the vote again
but we want people to come in legally
and through merit
through merit where they can help us
the radical democrats will implement
nationwide catch and release you know
what that is you catch a killer
you catch a rapist and you say oh thank
you very much please give us your name
oh come back in three years we're going
to put you on trial that's a lie
you never see them by the way remember i
had that debate with joe biden he said
no they come back yeah
they don't come back they don't come
back no they don't come back
like never maybe one percent but i doubt
it
that's the end of them you let them
loosen our country i got rid of it you
think that was easy
and install sanctuary cities all across
the country
very dehumanizing language green
criminal aliens and
ms-13 gang members the most vicious
people
they don't like guns because it's not
painful enough they like using
if you're one of the senate candidates
standing off stage do you is
do you believe this is helping you win
on january 5th
on innocent families we've moved
thousands and thousands of ms-13
the hell out of our country we moved
them back to where they came from
and some we put in prison because
they're too dangerous to move back
because they'll try and figure a way you
know they're not stupid they're vicious
but they're not stupid sort of like
the democrats if you think about it
they'll confiscate privately owned
firearms and share
they will what they will do they will
share everything with themselves
only dangerous equipment and they will
totally cut up
a thing called your second amendment
rights
that's not they'll make washington d.c a
state
and many other places guaranteeing two
four or six additional left-wing
senators i wish you know they want to
make numerous places states
i wish well you have a lot more louie
you can have a lot more
company in congress you'll have lots of
you'll have another 30 40
congressional people from places you've
never even heard of
you've never even heard of that that's
insane
oh my god covet louie's there and
they'll be voting against georgia
every time completely cancelling out
your voice in washington forever like
fingers crossed you will never forget it
you got hit by a piece of a hurricane
remember that the farmers got hit so
hard
and i went with sonny and with david and
some other great people from georgia
and i said is there a way we can pay
these people they never asked for
anything and their orchards were wiped
out
one of the men said this was going to be
the best crop i ever had i was a week
and a half away from
from finally after 10 12 years
making some money what is he talking
about
he gets hit by the remnants of that big
hurricane from florida
great state great place but you got hit
and david we took a hundred percent care
of those people right
we took a hundred percent yeah
with the help of sunny purdue secretary
of agriculture
and i felt so good but i met those you
know i met him there were 33 of them
standing and they were all in line what
do you do
isn't sunny perdue like 83 years old why
is he at a rally
with thousands of people during a global
pen like what what what the hell's going
on
they didn't want it these are incredible
people they don't want anything they
just want a level playing field but we
took care of them
they never forgot it either it's very
interesting i still hear from some of
those people
the extreme left will pack the supreme
court with 24 radical justices that's
the last number i heard
here it was 16 now i've never heard that
before
what soon you'll have another congress
24 radical justices instead of nine
justices that we have right now
also why would you make it an even
number that's very stupid
so that supreme court justices can spend
time in
other locations down the totem pole
they want to hurt the supreme court and
they want to hurt it very badly
and if these two don't get in or
if i don't get into these dogs we got to
get the best would be all three
nothing will happen well that's not
happening
but they want to destroy the sanctity of
the supreme court the importance of the
supreme court
the majesty of the supreme court they'll
terminate religious liberty cancel free
speech and force you to fund extreme
late term
sir we're canceling free speech
[Applause]
and there will be nothing to stop them
if they don't get in
there's going to be nothing to stop them
you have no idea how bad it will be
there will be nothing
i used to argue with certain people
about the filibuster i said look
i don't like it either but i do it
because i know they're going to do it
everybody said oh they'll never do it
then
they're doing it they've already
announced they're gonna do it nobody's
done anything
they can do anything they want and you
know the republicans they play a
different
game i don't know maybe they love the
country more but they
said no no they'll never do it and i
said i see people in chat saying that
there's some of the crowd is leaving
already people from the background i
haven't noticed that is that true
do it and he will do that to the supreme
court there's no question but they look
forward to it
because you know why we put on three
think of this three great justices
and and
will be over 300 federal
judges in the united states which will
be a record
300 300
and they don't want to wait they want to
do it very quickly let's just vote and
we'll
take it you know this takes years and
years and years to slowly change the
court
and perhaps i got a little bit lucky to
get three a lot of presidents have had
none they've never had they
stay on for a long time they're young
when they go on and they're old when
they come off
but the fact is a lot of presidents good
presidents great presidents who
they say you can't be a great president
unless you've put in who says that
who says that's the single most
important thing a president can do
and i'm not sure that's right i think
military defense military offense
frankly
is the most important military offense
but it's
certainly one of the most important
things you can do
and the fact that i have more than i
will have by the end
more than 300 first term think of it
and if we do a second term which i hope
we do we could have close to
540. guys i'd really like a second term
please but the fact that i had three
supreme court justices
in the first term is not making them
feel too good
they will unilaterally surrender to
china they're already doing it they're
already doing it and
you know hunter made a lot of money in
china what's he going to do
sending our factories and our jobs
overseas
they will raise your taxes we lowered
your taxes
we gave you the greatest tax decrease
tax cut
in the history of our country
and they want to get rid of that and
raise your taxes and raise your
regulations
this lady really liked that more
regulations than any president
in the history of our country that's one
of the reasons our business came back
you know with the pandemic as bad as it
is it's horrible
should have never happened china china
allowed this to happen should it never
happen
right you know we went down less a lot
of people don't like to talk our economy
we went down less and we went up more
than any other country in the world
we went down less because we had a good
foundation
and yesterday again so now i thought it
was 48 it's actually 128 times can you
believe it
new stock market record but this one was
great because
the dow jones industrial average over
think of this
over 30 000 for the first time ever over
the last couple of weeks
and yesterday it was thirty thousand
two hundred can you believe this and
this is during hopefully what will be
we're rounding the turn we're rounding
the corner on the pandemic
but this is during a pandemic we broke
30 000
a number that was unthinkable when i
first came when i first came in at
around 16
000 the concept of hitting a 30 000
dow was not even possible and we not
only hit
we can you imagine if we didn't get hit
by this
this freak this total freak that came
into our country can you imagine
if we didn't get trump remembers calling
some of his classmates total freaks in
middle school
did this sort of twice we took it
from the time i came in to the time we
got hit and nobody's blaming
us for that every country 188 got hit
some were totally
devastated i don't know if they ever
recover but we if you think about it
we had two we did it the first time we
went up from where i took it over
way up then it went down then we had a
second so we really had two
crystal clear get money because we want
the money first of all
these states and cities should open up
they should open up
and we're working hard against the
democrats but we're working hard
to get some money out to the people
because they need it it's not their
fault that they got hit
with something from china and do you
notice the way the democrats like to say
it came from italy no it came from china
and that's okay to say it they like to
say it came from europe no actually well
specifically it came from italy
italy saying what did we do
they'll wage war on american energy
absolutely decimating georgia's middle
class they will
your bills will go up not a huge energy
producer but texas remember they said
trump will lose texas by a lot i said
wait a minute i'm in favor of energy i'm
the one that built we have the greatest
energy we've ever had
and it all happened perfect energy
[Music]
you're telling me you're telling me that
i'm going to lose texas to a guy that's
against fracking
against energy is he at all going to
talk about the senate races i wonder or
is this going four hours tonight so much
somebody said we don't even know how
much and we knew that before but it's
fake news
they said wisconsin a poll came out
washington post abc
just before the election i'm going to
lose wisconsin by 17 points i said no
i'm going to win wisconsin
well actually i want wisconsin they're
trying to say he's a little down
no no you lost you lost yeah that's
called
suppression that's called depression
paul that's a poll that's so devastating
when i asked if you're just joining us
trump has lost his mind again so far why
don't they just say four or five
because in four years they're going to
lose all respect they don't care they'll
do anything to win they'll do anything
to beat you
they don't care these people are sick 17
points
and we actually won remember so many of
the states
i won every one of them every one of
these states and by the way
the swing states that we're all fighting
over now i won them all by them you won
them all guys
he won every state and i have to say
if i lost i'd be a very gracious
loser yeah right if i lost i would say
i lost and i'd go to florida and i'd
take it easy and i'd go around and i'd
say i did a good job
but you can't ever accept when they
steal
and rig and rob this is sick
can't accept
[Applause]
it's just like he just lost this is
well the democrats did try to steal
the presidency they're trying like hell
do you ever notice the fake news
today he's appointing his this is that
yeah sonny his secretary of
agriculture sunny i like sunny we want
sonny
was a great governor here for eight
years right
you would have uh you would have solved
this problem in about two hours honey
imagine biden appointing people
open let the let the vote let us be
transparent on signatures i think that's
okay
but we're working hard to ensure that it
doesn't happen and now they're trying to
steal
these two important senate seats from
georgia
and these seats are the last line of
defense to save america and protect
all that we have accomplished and you
know we've accomplished things that no
other president has
accomplished no other administration and
i did it with these two people i don't
know that i'd call them accomplishments
but it's true
i didn't really know what to think there
is nobody that fought harder for me and
i have to tell you this i'll tell you
you might be telling
you like publicly is that okay there is
nobody david understands this too
she fought what a trooper she was so
tough and smart she even went against
mitt romney she didn't like mitt romney
okay she said i won't say what she said
but it was tough but she is uh
we call him kryptonite you know anything
he touches they lose
but you were so great and i'll not
forget it and david's been my friend for
a long time for a long time it's funny
like he's
these are the people the rally
supposedly is supposed to help
than david perdue there's nobody there's
nobody so we have to keep them
if the other side manages to steal both
elections
we will have total one-party socialist
control
no socialists none of them are
socialists we'll be gone your whole
philosophy is going to be gone joe biden
kamala kamala
crying chuck schumer and nancy pelosi
they want to take away your guns i never
got it i never got it that's one of the
reasons i knew
how can you win no oil no guns
no god oh they won i don't think so okay
i don't know
wow that's very dumb very stupid a long
time ago
they want to take away your jobs take
away your borders
take away your freedom take away your
religion and they even want to
take away your beautiful christmas that
we just got very dangerous rhetoric
we just got christmas you know i sort of
imitate that right
do you remember i was saying suburban
women i say suburban women love me
please love me i've been so good for you
i've been so good to you i got rid of
the worst
regulation in the history of suburbia
i got rid of that regulation so now you
can actually
have a house without a building going up
next to it he got rid of the regulation
he thought made it easier for black
people to move in
even though it actually didn't i said
but suburban women please
please love me and cnn put me on donald
trump
donald trump is begging he's begging and
crying
for the vote of suburban weapons right
these people are sick so you have to be
very careful
when you're sarcastic sarcasm doesn't
work
sarcasm doesn't work with a wow that is
a big group of people back there look at
that
the fake news will he call for the
cameras to be turned around
that's a big group
that is a lot of fake news
well now we call it the fake news and
suppression news i use the word
suppression
because now they got a new thing going
this happened since hunter
because we were killing them on hunter
you know stealing money from every
country a laptop from hell
vacuum cleaner and it was hurting them
badly
so all of a sudden big tech together
with their partner the democrats and
their partner
the fake news media they decide under no
circumstances will we ever talk about it
again
so you have 95 of the media
you could have him be jesse james and
walk into the bank
with a gun hold them up give me all your
money this is a real conspiracy theory
it's hard to have a scandal
if they don't talk about it other than
the new york post
and people like sean hannity people like
laura and is doing good i like
tucker langley tucker and our friends in
the morning and i tell you we have some
great new people
oen yep
[Applause]
yes
put out a map with trump having like 409
electoral votes or something
and judge jeanine she's on right she's
on tonight
and jesse waters is great and he waters
and i'm in trouble because i don't
mention everybody but we have uh
we have great people we have a great
voice but the fact is
most of the press was it was suppressed
so that
no matter what they wouldn't talk and
it was incredible and i have to give a
lot of credit to i'm finding this
woman's nodding
very weaponized they went out and they
fought him and they fought
[Music]
oldest paper in america fourth or fifth
biggest
and they should be very proud of
themselves but we're doing the same
thing
these two incredible people are doing
the same thing we fight
if you don't get out and vote they are
going to win now you know a lot of
people friends of mine
say let's step up we're not going to
vote because we're angry about the
presidency interesting they're friends
of mine
they're people that are great people
they're they're real friends and more
than just two there are
numerous people wow and it's almost like
a protest but if you do that
the radical left wins ah
it was sort of an instinctive mind you
know you're angry because so many votes
were stolen it was taken away
and you say well we're not going to do
it we can't do that we have to actually
do just the opposite
we can't do that we can't do that we
have to do just the opposite
if you don't vote the socialists and the
communists
win they win there's none running
there's none in government
for these two incredible people and i'm
telling you they're two of the finest
people you'll ever meet we can fight for
the presidency and fight to elect our
two great senators and we can do it at
the same time we'll do it at the same
time
it's all right the election is about hey
moderators just a heads up we're
we're getting invaded a little bit by
some trolls let's just keep an eye out
it's just unbelievable how she picked it
up no but
you know this natural talent i always
say as an athlete i'd always say
would you rather practice or have
natural talent i said the best is both
right
but she's got a great natural talent a
great natural talent
just very respected yeah but they
believe both of them in america and they
believe in our values and all isn't this
woman the star of a few viral videos
where she's yelling at minorities at a
walmart
because i love you stay tuned by the way
this election is about the radical left
movement that hates america
and wants to erase our history and wipe
away everything that we hold dear
they want to rip down our statues you
know i signed a
bill i took an old bill because we could
never get it today in the house headed
by
crazy nancy i took an old bill
that said 10 years in prison they use
the word prison not jail
10 years in prison if you take down a
statue i haven't seen it happen lately
do you notice
everyone said you can't use that i'll
never forget
i heard they were gonna you know they
did destruction around and all in
radical left
democrat-run cities by the way and we're
not supposed to go in i don't know if i
had to do again
austin's a mess it's crazy what's going
on
we're not supposed to they're supposed
to be able to handle their own affairs i
don't know
but but all over they said sir you can't
do this bill this is too tough i said
really sir they're going to tear down a
statue of abraham lincoln george
washington
thomas jefferson desecrate the most
beautiful pieces of art and they
represent
our country confederate statues or
pieces of art now
i told you we can't let it happen over
the last four years david perdue
has been one of the toughest fighters
for our america first
america first agenda in washington
and david saw this did you see last week
china said
china doesn't like me too much they pay
us billions and billions that never
happened billions and billions of
dollars in tariffs and they pay it they
devalued their currency he still doesn't
get it a lot of money
they don't like me the happiest people
in the world right now
are the leaders of china the second
happiest are the leaders of
iran we would have what we would have
done in the next four years
oh so he's conceding so he won't be here
but china said all right we will not
deal with you
unless you get rid of the america first
policy
and you know what the democrats are ill
oh my god they said yes we will do that
can you believe this
[Applause]
and that's when i realized what a
brilliant name that is you know we come
up with some good ones but that's a good
one we came up with plenty of good ones
haven't we
some of them i won't use because some of
those people are now friends of mine but
why is he screaming in america first and
i looked at
melania a week ago and i said can you
believe it
they are saying that they don't agree
with america first how do you say that
and she said sir we don't agree
with america first we agree with china
yes we will get rid of america first
policy i think david
you don't like that too much right and
if they're here
it won't happen because nothing's going
to be able to get past
that's not going to be reasonable he
fought to pass the largest package
david huge package cuts and reforms in
american history
he helped leave the effort to repeal a
record number of job-killing regulations
the likes of which you've never seen
including the unfair
waters of the united states rule that
crippled
work for our farmers and our builders
this guy with his kids leaving in the
background they're out of here
destroying people
and i'll never waters of the united how
beautiful is that waters of the united
states and i said
i got to get rid of it i got to do it
but i'm going to get killed
because the only thing good about it was
the title waters what are you doing
today i'm terminating waters of the
united states
well it was a little bit like the paris
environmental accord right
the paris environmental accord i said
i'm going to get killed in this one
we'll be back in it within seven weeks
and trillions of dollars russia has a
big advantage of us they go back to
old days when the air was very dirty
that was their standard
china doesn't kick in until 2030
we kick it immediately and the money
that would have cost
us and if we adhere to it we would have
had it close up 20 percent of our
factories
and now the first thing they want to do
john kerry great negotiator
the first thing they want to do is they
want to number one they want to bring
back the paris accord
carrie's smarter than anyone that works
for trump
that was designed to destroy the united
states
the second thing they want to do is
let's give iran billions of dollars oh
they're so happy
[Applause]
iran would have been in my office in the
first hour
after we won the election to make a deal
so you guys are right there are a lot of
people walking out yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
after hurricane michael devastated our
farmers in southwest georgia as i said
no one worked harder
to get them relief than david perdue he
would call me all the time he actually
called me more than sunny and sonny said
agriculture what the hell's going on son
sonny what happened to you sonny it's
true david would call all the time
and remember how tough the democrats met
they didn't want to give them anything
but we got it we got them more than they
even thought possible
senator perdue helped pass the
unprecedented 2.5 trillion dollar
investment in our united states military
delivering the largest pay raises in
addition to everything else
for our warriors in a decade we now have
the greatest most modern military in the
history of our country we have brand new
fighter jets brand new bombers
brand new missiles and rockets remember
a couple months ago some of the
enlightened leftists in the
the sort of uh like uh revolutionary
left saying
trump's against the military industrial
complex
we have them all we have missiles that
go seven times faster than any missile
in the world
best missiles
cheering for missiles our military was
decimated
our military was tired our military was
in big trouble
and you remember and i've said it a lot
one of the world's most overrated
generals came to see me
he said sir we have no ammunition sir we
had a little problem with a certain
country
and he said sir we have no ammunition i
said tell me you're not saying that
we didn't have ammunition think of it we
had very little ammunition and
i'll never forget that statement i said
that should never happen to a president
of the united states again nor should
being spied on ever happened to a
president of the united states
right senator perdue has been a
tremendous leader on pro-american
immigration reform like nobody else
he voted very powerfully when i was
going through hell on the wall
they would have given me anything they
gave me the money for the military they
just didn't want to give me money
for the world so i took it out of the
military what the hell can i do
that was rather good it's good to be a
developer every once in a while
that was the one where the judges ruled
yesterday so they said it was fun
because i called it national security
so we took it out of the mill they
didn't figure that one out now they do
but you know what they don't have to be
careful because it's a very sick man
popular very successful granting and
renting
sanctuary cities and chain migration
and protect american jobs david did he
voted to confirm
nearly 300 of the judges that i talked
about the federal judges that interpret
the constitution as written
and when the democrat mob came for judge
kavanaugh
david perdue stood strong
defiant david perdue
and you know i'm just thinking they both
stood strong when they impeached your
president for making it yeah so he took
the money from the military or he or i
thought mexico was going to pay for the
wall now i'm confused
for making a perfect phone call but
those two were among the best
senator perdue more people leaving he's
an outsider a businessman a great
businessman and a true american patriot
you need him fighting the imagery of the
people heading for the exits is funny
because the united states senate cannot
be the same without him
so that's why i'm here you know i don't
do these things for other people in fact
i was curious i didn't know if anyone
was going to show up i said i'm doing
good for other people
this is a hell of a crowd look as far as
the eye can turn the cameras around
as far as the eye
i don't like doing it for other people
i said david and kelly called would you
do a rally i said not really i did 56 of
them in a
little tiny period of time i said let me
have and i said
uh when they asked i it was really not
but you know i don't do them for other
people it's a lot of work to do a rally
a lot of work people don't realize when
you do i did five a day the last
four or five guys you people don't you
realize flying around on a private jet
to read the same speech everywhere in
front of a crowd of sycophants that's
really hard work
what do you guys do by the way it's fun
in some of them it's
uh 75 degrees and in others it's
20 degrees below zero sometimes it's
cold
i'm saying how's the weather out there
sir it's about 20 degrees below zero
that's good
then i land the next stop how are we
doing sir it's 82.
too hot too cold too sunny is a radical
left wing zealot
nice transition very proud to be
endorsed by
look at ossoff's actual policy positions
he's like
a center-left democrat the crazy
green new deal that's another beauty
don't forget the green new deal is
really a hundred trillion dollars okay
it's a hundred trillion dollars they
don't say that louis do they they talk
about three trillion it got down to
three trillion no it's a hundred
trillion is what they wanted
that's more money if our economy was
going
unbelievable gangbusters for a hundred
years no recession no anything
we couldn't come close to making 100
trillion they want to rip down buildings
and rebuild them with no windows i like
windows i like big beautiful windows
and low flow toilets he wants to do a
total
government takeover of health care that
will destroy your doctor's offices
and rural hospitals so if you are sick
if you call if you have a cold go to a
hospital wait online for about three
days
and hope you get a decent doctor ossoff
also supports a crippling nationwide
lockdown
he wants you to lock your home nice and
tight after you're inside of it no one
supports that
and he passes legislation to let
hardened criminals go free get them out
of jail get them out of jail
ossoff will be a complete tool for the
radical left owners
who are trying to buy georgia senate
seats do you see the money these people
have raised
i mean it's it's really uh it's very uh
well of course i just raised 250 million
dollars this woman sees the money that
was raised i didn't raise it it just
i said how we doing in that front you
know because we didn't get great
publicity boys were they they were so
happy these guys
don't you might not be happy in a few
weeks you know you might not
right because trump's going to be
president again
i said how's fundraising going they said
sir
250 million i said 250 million what
dollars
how the hell did that happen because
people believe in what we're doing
that's why
[Music]
but that's why ossoff's donations come
from silicon valley
san francisco and the other liberal
places and they don't come from georgia
this is not your i know you you're with
me i'm with you
we've always had wins from primaries to
two elections we won two elections
believe it or not
i think i won the second one by more
than i won the first one there it is
there's an idea
bill sure i won the second one by more
he won guys on january 5th you also need
to vote
for your incredible republican senator
kelly lefler kelly has been an
exceptional champion for georgia's
workers and families
and i know what they fight for if i
could tell you about david i could tell
you about kelly
she fights for you every single day
loves your state when our nation was hit
with the china virus
senator lefler helped rescue the u.s
economy by
voting to pass a historic three trillion
dollar
bill relief for american workers and
families and a lot of people were
against it and it turned out to be a
great thing kelly
right a lot of people said oh it's too
much i said it's not their fault and i
want to get them more money now
and i like the higher number rather than
the lower number we'll make it back
with her help we secured 15 billion
dollars for
175 000 georgia small businesses
and saved 1.5 million
georgia jobs that was both of them
really both of them
kelly is a relentless advocate for
georgia farmers
and she is fortunate kelly is maybe the
most corrupt senator
maybe and that's it's tough actually
because there's a lot of contenders
there in man who's one of the most
respected
men in the country i want to tell you
that i want to tell you that
he's a great man he's a great gentleman
at the urging of you know if you're
successful today it's supposed to be a
bad thing no i think it means you're
smart sometimes right
he's a smart guy but he's a great guy
he's a great man
at the urging of kelly and david my
administration took historic action to
protect growers of georgia
blueberries peppers squash and cucumbers
who
who does cucumbers around here because i
like cucumbers can you i'm the only one
i like you his cutes when our law
enforcement heroes were under attack
senator lefleur stood up to the marxists
and introduced legislation to protect
our brave men and women in blue
and she was threatened all over the
place that threat meant nothing that was
a wasted
number of phone calls or however the
hell i'm big on broccolini i love bro i
think
broccolini is just a great vegetable
introduce legislation to prevent
democrat
gun grabbers like beto o'rourke remember
beto
there's a guy who has another one he
wants to take your guns away
oh by the way trump is going to lose
texas but beto o'rourke who's a big
factor in that whole thing
remember when beto was running he was
riding high
and then ted cruz has done a great job
beat beto o'rourke
but beta was riding high for a while and
remember he made he was on the cover of
a certain really bad magazine i won't
mention the name it's failing it won't
be in business for another
six months i don't think i hope but he
was on the cover
and he said i was born to do this
and i said anybody that says they were
born to do this
more people leaving very quickly and you
know what within about two months he was
a stone cold loser
and just weeks ago senator lefler cast
her vote to confirm our newest supreme
court justice
amy coney barrett
okay they both did by the way
they both did i can't leave david out of
that one
kelly's opponent a lot of people leaving
guys
is a dangerous extremist who is
radically opposed to
your values he said he believes that
quote
nobody can serve god and the military
oh really an appalling statement
that dishonors the memory and
generations of american heroes who
fought
for god and for our country rafael
warnock
has openly declared his support for
socialism
and he has even praised marxists all
over the world
he once hosted the barbaric communist
dictator
fidel castro lex castro i think he was a
good man he was a good guy he said
he falsely slandered patriotic americans
as racists
he called police officers gangsters
thugs and bullies
he supports abolishing cash bail look at
what happened to new york with their
cash cash bail no no bail don't worry
about it you killed somebody don't worry
about it you know
you're on the honor code and he's
declared quote
open up the jails free the violent
criminals
and prey on georgia families children
now you can't do that this is not for
georgia yet i'm telling you
it might be for some places and i tell
you that too this is not for georgia i
think
rafael has to move to another state try
it again
warnock is strongly anti-israel people
checking in
um we're about 75 minutes into this and
only the last 10 roughly have been
actually about
the senate races in any kind of real way
we did something i shouldn't be doing
this for them it costs too much money
but we'll do it anyway
we have a little video to play please oh
no
not the video senator sanders senator
warren and myself
are all on the same team what are you
willing to sacrifice
to make sure that over-funded police
departments are defined
there is no middle road on the climate
crisis i not only support a green new
deal i don't think it goes far enough
i'm all for a green new deal this is
part of what gun registration
is about we want to track where the guns
are we need to cut
really done either chick-fil-a
oh popeye are you in favor of expanding
the court
or perhaps an age limit uh in place
instead of a lifetime appointment
but i've said everything is on the table
but if we win the majority everything is
on the table
now we take georgia and then we change
america
change is coming to america the blue
wave
is comprised of those who are documented
and undocumented we win these races in
georgia so that we
don't have to negotiate
that's their goal total radical control
to bring horrific
jobs to america only georgians can stop
them
nobody can serve god on the military
rafael warnock attacks our military how
long do you think trump's gonna
go on today gangsta and fog mentality
warnock attacks our police
negotiating that's their goal
total radical control to bring horrific
change to america
only georgians can stop them nobody can
serve
god on the military rafael warnock
attacks our military
police power the kind of gangster
and fog mentality warnock attacks
our police somebody's gotta open up the
jails
raphael warnock is dangerous no wonder
he defended this
not god bless america
now my hope is that uh in early january
democrats will pick up
two more seats in the georgia runoffs uh
and that will make our life
a lot easier we need to send a message
this year
we need to send a message that if you
indulge in this kind of politics
you're going to get beaten so bad he can
never run or show your face again in
public
because we have enough absolutely enough
of what we are getting from donald trump
and his fellow travelers right now
so the guy they just showed getting
punched in that video that's the guy who
was going around
violently attacking people in the time
leading
up to that like that every aspect of
that is so deceptive it's crazy
they showed up and it was incredible
hundreds of thousands of people people
couldn't believe
now of course some of the fake news said
hundreds of people are here no no no
tens of thousands of people and you know
antifa
antifa
[Music]
not the right but the left showed up
and they looked at some of these people
and they wanted to attack the crowd they
looked and they said
no thank you and they left no problem
they looked at some of these people when
was this then it broke up about three
o'clock
everyone went home very peacefully it
was a beautiful day actually
they all went home peacefully and that
night they came back
and there were a few families that
stayed around with young children
and there were some elderly people that
were having dinner in washington
very elderly people very elderly those
people got attacked
viciously efficiently by the scum from
antifa
we can't let this happen we can't let
this happen
but what they didn't play what the fake
news didn't play is
during the day they walked in and they
wanted to do some damage and they took a
look and they said
uh no thank you we won't do it we'll
wait we'll wait till we get the people
with the children
we'll wait till we get the elderly
people that want to stay in washington
and and really just have a good time
and it was disgusting to watch on
january 5th
you must defeat us off and warn up and
send two great people david perdue and
kelly lefler back to the center
looks like the conclusion and if you
don't mind i'd like to ask david
and kelly to come up and see him no oh
this is going to be a mess
get ready for some real bonkers stuff
trump seems bored honestly
[Applause]
like he's just waiting for it to be over
oh my god look at these people
thank you georgia thank you mr president
president trump
you made america great again because you
put
america first thank you
president trump created the strongest
economy because he put the american
worker first he stood up that's right
he stood up to the canceled this woman
is vile
big tech the fake news we
are standing strong for president trump
because he's fought for us
every single day disgusting woman
really really violently georgia we need
you to
vote january 5th if you're our voice on
january 5th we'll be your voice for
years
we have to make sure that we keep
america strong
okay thank you very little applause well
you know what
my colleague david perdue my good friend
wants to make sure that you vote we are
going to vote
because if we don't vote we will lose
the country
if we vote we will win
hey guys i want to take larry in just
one second
hey why won't you debate john also
personal to president trump how about
debating john austin
say something for president trump
firstly guys
i want to say something personal for
president trump trump
god bless you we love you mr president
we love the first lady
and we're going to fight and win those
two seats and make sure you get a fair
square deal how about a debate did god
bless you mr president
they hand him the mic now
but he had a mic
the crowd's just done
what are they chanting five more
fight for trump
thank you thank you trump's hair has
turned green it's weird
we're gonna fight like you never saw
before thank you
we can't let what happened three weeks
ago we can't let it happen not it's
beyond me
we can't let it happen and somewhere
there's going to be a champion you're a
champion
some way there's going to be a champion
that's going to do what's right because
this has been going on for a long time
but never like it's happened recently
and you know they've used the pandemic
and the phony fake ballots the mail-in
ballots
they use that to sabotage a country
we're not going to let it happen as you
know
a major issue in this state is voter
fraud it's been a big issue for a long
trial
never like this we sent out
tens of thousands millions and millions
of ballots
nobody knew where they came from where
they are people were getting two
three four ballots signing them sending
them in
what a mess and i said it a year ago and
i said it every month
and i even said let's postpone the
election and they said oh he's not an
american you know
they knew what they were doing they knew
what they were doing we're all deeply
disturbed and upset by the lying
cheating
robbing stealing that's gone on with our
elections
we know the democrats will have dead
people voting
and you got to watch it dead people you
wouldn't believe they'll be dead and
voting
from out of the state and they'll be
filing out
and filling out ballots for people who
don't even exist they put up what a
stupid argument signing their own name
over and over they have
they have people signing names with the
same pen
with the same signature they don't even
change
because they know once they get it in
it'll never be looked at
it'll never be looked at again because
of people like your secretary of state
and your governor
so we want signature verification
but the answer and we're going to be
very careful we're going to watch every
ballot david and kelly we can't let this
happen again and again we have more
light
shining here because of what happened
right because of the fact it's
pinpointed
the answer to the democrat fraud is not
to stay at home
that's what nancy pelosi and schumer
that's what they want you to do
actually there's been republicans saying
stay home
if you want to do something to them i
don't want to use the word revenge but
it is a certain revenge
to the democrats you show up and vote in
record numbers that's what you have to
do
they can only win if they cheat they
can't win this state unless they cheat
and they cheat better than anybody you
know when you think of it
the republicans are much nicer they're
not nearly as vicious
maybe a few of us republicans are too
nice he said you're right
that's a very good thank you very much i
like that but they are they're too nice
they don't go after these criminals they
got to go after them
we're talking to people go after them
they don't go after them
what they're afraid they'll hurt their
reputation when they get out i don't
know
they don't go after them but we're
watching this so closely we have
everybody watching
you gotta get out and vote let them
steal georgia again you'll never be able
to look yourself in the mirror
is he winding down the line and you have
two of the greatest people on earth do
you have to hold the line make sure that
you and everyone else know that you have
to register to vote before this monday
december 7th
is that right monday december 7th you
have to
register to vote of course you'll
probably be allowed to if you're a
democrat you know they don't have
any time limits did you see where
what a buffoon stacy is allowed to
harvest
but other people can't harvest how is
that constitutional
how is that she reportedly harvested
massive dumps of blueberries and
raspberries
dot gov and register immediately then
request your absentee ballot before
december 31st don't delay watch it
closely
do it today do it tomorrow and return
your ballot the same day you get it
so they can't say gee it didn't come in
on time you know what they did in one of
the states
ballots were coming in late very very
late so they backdated the
ballots we have all the information we
have all the we have so much evidence
why don't judges buy it in court oh they
don't have enough evidence we have
hundreds and hundreds and even thousands
of affidavits
and they say uh he doesn't have the
evidence we have so much evidence we
don't know what to do with it
i'm saying do we put all of this into a
filing it's like with wheelbarrows
if you aren't planning to vote by mail
wheelbarrows of evidence
person or vote on election day whatever
you do i need
each of you every one of you your
friends your family to go
and vote
[Applause]
his heart's not really in it and after
we win we need to pass
landmark election reform including voter
id
is that so bad
residency verification like we live in
the country we live in this state
citizenship confirmation they want to
say oh he doesn't have to be a citizen
you got to see what's voting these
they're not citizens you're a citizen no
i'm not
this is insane there's no no no english
speaking completely corrosive
yeah this is the crazy not speaking
english is different
than not being a citizen although you do
need some level of english to pass the
citizenship test right
sure you had a photo id very stupid it
comes to the most important thing voting
they don't want to do it and they know
they know exactly
we just can't let that happen i've only
been doing this for a short time
believe me this is something we're going
to do because we can't allow it to
happen
and complete overhaul of our election
security systems
because right now dominion is a joke
okay right not a very funny joke
it's a disgrace that in 2020 no state in
america even makes any real attempt
to verify that those who cast ballots by
mail are eligible
and lawfully registered voters the
evidence of fraud is overwhelming and
again
i'm going to ask you to look up at that
very very powerful and very expensive
screen
again let's go oh my god wait
let's switch over here it's a disgrace
that in 2020
no state in america even makes any real
attempt
to verify that those who cast ballots by
mail are eligible oh did we miss it
the accounting room i think we missed
with no observers
with no media hidden cases of possible
ballots
or rolled out from under a table four
people
under a cloud of suspicion begin what
looks an awful lot
this has already been debunked i hope
you guys know
that and the media did oh wait atlanta
georgia ballot counters being told to
leave the counting room
then a short time later with no
observers with no media this has already
been debunked
possible so dumb or rolled out from
under a table
four people under a cloud of suspicion
begin
a cloud looks an awful lot like ballot
stuffing and the media did pack up and
leave at 11
15. but there weren't observers there
um at that time and there was no
announcement made
for anyone to leave now wait a second
here that
is disheveled fulton county elections
chief richard barron
shovels but he doesn't have the facts
right video proves it
at 10 40 p.m not 11 15 10 40 the media
is packing
up a half hour before he thinks they
leave you can see them putting on their
jackets there
and by 10 56 so this has already been
widely debunked and actual election
workers explained like no those ballots
weren't
hidden like the we we knew that the
ballots were there we were counting
ballots sequentially
just because you know you put a little
interest circle around an area of the
screen
doesn't or a person doesn't make it what
you want it to be
it's like it's actually it's actually so
boring to leave
and if you look at this table there are
ballots in boxes
open and understand that nobody's
willing to go in and do and
and do this stuff under oath all the
hearings nobody's under oath
in the actual court filings they never
say we believe there was fraud
when they're asked in court are you
alleging fraud they say well no we're
just saying people didn't
see some stuff um what you have to do is
you can't go by what's said on newsmax
you have to go by what they're saying in
courts
ballots were under a table versus
being in the open
well i think there there's this i
i don't know that they're i think those
those ballot boxes get
heavy i don't think they want to be
lifting those things up
and putting them back down
he makes no sense the guy's scratching
his head he just looks nervous
the guy does not inspire confidence
there were already ballots out but even
almost 24 hours since i posted
what could be quote smoking gun video
of election fraud a video now with 2.5
million
views as of right now it's been debunked
the head of elections whose ballot
counters are now
it's actually embarrassing also that a
president promotes stuff from newsmax
like that's the real embarrassment
i i need to review the video i have not
seen the video please do
please do is right he hasn't watched the
video
that could up end the presidential
election and the guy in charge
of the very people in the room admits he
didn't watch the video before
updating board members this morning
that's insanity
and yet fulton county still certified
the election but you know who did watch
our video
our viewers stingfields army one
directed me to this moment in the video
the woman in purple after putting
ballots in to be scanned
it appears to take the same batch of
ballots out
straighten them and then look what she
does with them
she reinserts them back the ballots have
a unique identifier right so like the
machines literally can't count the same
ballot two times unless it wasn't read
the first time
may not be an explanation for this
but it certainly needs to be
investigated by law enforcement
as the greatest political heist in
election history
may have just been caught on camera
evidence of election fraud mounts as the
mainstream media and democrats loudly
insist
joe biden is still the 2020 winner
however
whistleblowers are coming forward with
credible information that hundreds of
thousands of votes for president trump
mysteriously disappeared on election
night on tuesday jesse morgan a worker
for the u.s postal service revealed that
his trailer full of ballots simply
went missing after he dropped them off
the worker drove his truck from bethpage
new york
all the way to lancaster pennsylvania
and says he was carrying some 288
000 completed mail-in ballots phil klein
the director of the legal group
thomas moore's society i i actually
can't believe they're just playing
entire
news max reports at these events
the project is working to discover flaws
and even exposed cases of voting fraud
in the 2020 election
and has already uncovered serious
examples of voting irregularities
backing up president trump's warnings
klein explains that the post office was
rife with fraud and that many postal
service workers were taking part in
widespread illegal efforts to undermine
oh this is oan sorry that the post
office in wisconsin had collected and
backdated over 100
000 ballots on the morning after the
election
unsurprisingly others also the 10-minute
video of dominion voting machines
has been compromised and cannot be
trusted during a press conference in
arlington virginia on tuesday
the project i'm watching this show the
barrier on netflix it's really
it's really good it's a spanish show and
it's sort of like a dystopian
uh uh police state and uh this screen
reminds me of the screen that's always
playing there with the same woman's
voice reminding people how to behave and
what to do
ballot hard drives were illegally
tampered with and broken
klein says that in total there are over
300
000 fraudulent ballots in arizona 548
000 in michigan
204 000 in georgia and 121
000 in pennsylvania this is nuts based
on this evidence the fbi has evidence
requested to look at the project's data
on voting integrity
and potential election fraud pearson
sharp
one america news
all right so let's get back over here
water main break you know they said
there was no border paper that's ten
times more
than i need to win this state ten times
more it's
10 times maybe more than that but it's
10 times more
because we lost by a very close number
the alleged biden margin of victory in
several states is entirely accounted for
by
extraordinarily large midnight vote
dumps you saw that here we go
huge dumps all extremely skewed
to biden like biden would get 10 000
votes and trump would get three
in a trump area oh for example
at 6 31 a.m in michigan reported
141 238 votes for joe biden
and 5 900 votes for donald trump
96 for biden four percent for trump
in an area where i should be doing quite
well you know i won almost every county
in michigan almost every district it was
a except for one
right they actually had more people
if you look at the ballots they had
ballots all over
they had more ballots than they had
people voting how do you do that
so they had people and they're voting
and then as you know
two of the canvassers were very brave
they didn't vote and they got the hell
knocked out canvassers
what they went through they took all the
cameras went off and then they raised
their hand but then they couldn't sign
it ultimately
but more ballots than they had voters
now how how simple is that a similar
vote dump occurred in wisconsin at 3 42
p.m this is 3 42 in the morning
in fact when i went to bed that night
everybody was calling congratulations
you're up six hundred thousand votes in
pennsylvania
across all of the key swing states there
were impossibly no
low rejection rates you saw that for
mail-in ballots drastically less
than the historic norm in georgia point
five percent of the mail-in ballots were
rejected in 2020 compared to 5.77
that's a difference of 11 times more
it's
hundreds of thousands of votes in
pennsylvania
point zero three percent were rejected
in 2020 compared to a much much higher
percentage in 2016 right this issue
alone is enough to change the election
results
in many states whistleblowers
so basically he did 15 minutes on the
senate and then otherwise it's been
election fraud claims
have testified to witnessing postal
workers and election workers illegally
backdating thousands and thousands
of ballots fixing ballots filling out
false birthdays
registering ineligible voters and much
much more
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of votes
in each state in arizona a sample of 100
ballots reviewed by a judge
found that a very small percentage of
these ballots
very small but when you look at it it
was turned out to be very large it was
tens of thousands of votes more than we
would have needed
to win arizona we should have won that
state very easily we have a similar type
of governor i think but i'll let you
know that in about a week
in one michigan county and by the way
when laura ingraham
interviewed your governor he said he was
an
offensive lineman i said that's strange
he doesn't look like an offensive
lineman to me in one michigan county
using dominion voting systems
nearly 6 000 votes were discovered that
were wrongly switched
from trump to biden they called it a
glitch
you know what glitch that's like the
machine bro completely unsubstantiated
found glitches
and every single time the glitch went
100 to biden
and no percent to trump these are
completely unsubstantiated lies
the left lies they cheat and they steal
they are ruthless
and they are hell-bent on getting power
and control by any
and he's been going for an hour and 35
minutes for people who are wondering
it's it's
unbelievable the moment you question
them
they try and intimidate you they call
you a poor american you're not a good
american
you don't love our country they don't
love our country they beat you down
shut you up and make you retreat
that's what they do that's what they've
done to your governor they've done that
to your governor
your governor should be ashamed of
himself that's what they want to do
right here in georgia they want you to
be quiet
they want you to go away but we don't go
away we don't go
it seems out of energy it's the biggest
open secret in america the democrats
cheat in elections
this year by sending out 65 million
mail-in ballots
they perpetrated the largest fraud in
the history of our country
democrat officials and politicians in
every swing state
systematically weakened every measure to
combat election fraud
they ensured that there were no identity
checks no
signature checks i want to check a
signature please i'm sorry we don't let
you do that
no eligibility checks no nothing
every single one of you know that if
these ballots are
properly audited if the signatures and
envelopes were examined
if the envelopes were correlated to the
votes
because you'll find there are far more
ballots than there are envelopes
all you have to do is count them up how
many ballots you have how many envelopes
do you have
and if the voter rolls are studied in
other words
studied to check the signature
miss smith oh it's a totally different
signature from two years ago from six
years ago from 10 years ago
what's that all about he's fading yeah
this is it's getting
sad we're illegally it went from
dangerous to just sad and weird
by the way more than enough to give us a
total
historic victory
this is our country
that they are taught and you know this
and you see it but they're trying to
take it
from us through rigging fraud deception
and deceit
that's what we saw in the election
that's what's going on and it's
happening right now in our country
i think we'll do something about it and
we're going to do something about it
quickly
and we're going to be watching on
january 5th
yeah we're going to be watching every
element of what they do this fraud
a lot of people leaving our country
we're going to be watching it
more closely than any election has ever
been watched
hopefully our legislatures and the
united states supreme court will
step forward and save our country it's
actually becoming
almost uh castro-like in its duration
without borders we don't have a country
i can say also without an
honest voting system without an
electoral process
that works and it's honest and fair we
don't have a country either
we need to check every single signature
in the presidential and senatorial
elections
and right now we have to get out to vote
for david perdue
and kelly lefler to show the radical
left that we will never surrender we
will only win we're going to win we
always win
somehow we find people heading for the
exit now is not the time this guy
doesn't know which way to go but he's
getting out
harder than ever before
so don't listen to my friends just go
out just
go out and you know what they're saying
they're saying we want you to fix the
system we're going to fix the system
but the system will be fixed when these
people get in
they'll get in and we'll fix this system
right because we're all
we're all victims everybody here all
these thousands of people here tonight
they're all victims every one of you the
next great
victory for our movement begins right
here on january 5th and then
we are going to look at the people
bailiff white house we're going to win
it back
and we're going to take back the house
in 2022
and then in 2024 and hopefully i won't
have to be a candidate
we're going to win back the white house
again win back the white house
wait we're gonna win a friend of mine
said oh don't worry about it sir
win back the polls you'll win in 2024. i
said i don't want to wait till 2024. i
want to go back three weeks
we're thrilled to be joined tonight by
some real friends of all of ours
representatives doug
collins oh my god
it was fantastic and by the way i gotta
tell you
as you know he and kelly had a great
primary a very strong primary
they both did fantastically well and he
is on board and he is one of the
greatest
vandaz digly oh more people heading for
the exits there they go
thank you doug what a job he does thank
you
doug you want to run for governor in two
years
yeah good-looking governor
a friend of mine one of the toughest
guys you'll ever see
louie gohmert of texas one of the most
extreme congressmen out there
and a young up-and-comer who's taken
washington by storm
dan crenshaw oh my god he's got crenshaw
there
that is funny i didn't see you dan
it's the first time that's ever happened
to me huh cause you do stand out in many
ways thank you very much
in many ways what is he talking about
the eye patch what does that mean just
got elected
did my endorsement help ah better
believe it we love tennessee
bill hagerty he's going to be a great
senator
he's going to be a great senator for a
long time you're a former
eight-year governor he only left because
of a thing called term limits
if i would have known i would have tried
to end those term limits
but he went to there you go department
of agriculture has his head he's done a
tremendous job
and you know we've handed out 28 billion
dollars to farmers 28 billion i said
how badly have we been targeted by china
and sonny perdue said over two year
periods here
28 billion dollars that's when i put the
tariffs on china took the money
and gave it out to the farmers and we
had a lot of money left over
and we put that into the u.s treasury
right sonny
and you've done a fantastic job he knows
more about farms than any human being
state representative a friend of mine a
great gentleman he saw what was
happening he happens to be a democrat
but we love him i'm trying to talk him
into joining our party
vernon jones
thank you very much so in only about uh
12 or so minutes
trump will enter the start of the third
hour of this speech
gary good job you're doing boy
what a good reputation thank you very
much gary your public service
commissioners
trisha pridemore jason shawn a great man
great great man who's also on the ballot
next month bubba
mcdonald i like that name where's bubba
trisha
great great job great job that's great
thanks a lot bubba
and i introduce you to uh burt jones
bert's going to be a very important man
i think over the next coming with
william and brandon and
the folks and and i appreciate it and
greg thank you very much for being here
we appreciate it people starting to call
for mercy bands yeah i understand that
republican party chairman david shaffer
david hi david how we doing david
oh we'll fire you so fast if we don't
now david's done a great great job and
he works very closely with
rnc chairwoman this is how we won we won
a great state
we want a great state known as michigan
when she was there and i said let's
bring her to
washington and then he lost thank you
rona
thank you
thank you rana over the last four years
we've built the greatest political
movement
he's got another stanza we've achieved
more than anyone thought possible
and we're just getting started and we
don't want other people to rip it apart
we must re-elect kelly and david to keep
it going for decades our politicians
spent trillions and trillions of dollars
rebuilding other foreign nations
fighting foreign wars and defending
foreign borders we want to defend our
border if it's okay and we're now
finally protecting our nation
rebuilding our cities and we are
bringing our jobs
our factories and our troops back home
to the usa where they belong right
bringing them home not easy to bring
them home i
bring them home and they say well sir we
got to keep them there sir
we got to keep spending money we've got
to keep giving money to these countries
that can't stand us that nobody ever
heard of
and everything we do we are putting
america first we ended the war in
american energy
and the united states is now the number
one producer of oil
and natural gas anywhere on earth
we achieved the most secure border in
u.s history
and we built our wall as i said
very important for you because you're a
big military
between the equipment we build and va
choice and va accountability right
right you ever noticed the vets you used
to always have
on television you'd have the fake news
that always be well in that case it
wasn't fake but for years
you'd always see vets how badly treated
they were how badly treated
i shouldn't say this because they'll
find one somewhere in the country but
you don't see that
you don't see that anymore you don't see
the stories on the evening news about
vets that are being
treated horribly and accountability was
a big factor we fired 9 000
horrible people that took advantage of
our vets terrible people
and now of our vets don't an obama
policy but i mean it's like they see a
doctor
how many times am i going to tell you
guys don't wait online for weeks and
months
[Music]
we destroyed 100 of the isis caliphate
in iraq and syria
we killed the leader of isis al-baghdadi
and we eliminate the world's
top terrorists solimani is dead
i withdrew from the last
administration's disastrous
iran nuclear deal and i think they want
to start it up again can you believe
this
i wonder if they'll give them 150
billion no they'll give them 250.
they were ready to rock they were ready
to do whatever we wanted now they're
gonna
they're salivating i recognized the true
capital of israel and opened the
american embassy in jerusalem
disastrous idea and jared was going to
solve the conflict within the first term
the golan heights instead of endless war
we are forging peace
all over the world and you know we have
the greatest military ever we have the
greatest equipment all made in the usa
a lot of it made in georgia but you know
what
we've created i'm the only one in many
many decades
that hasn't started a war everyone
thought that with my personality
i'd be in war the first week they're all
saying war
and we've developed relationships let's
see how
he would do with kim jong-un of north
korea i don't think
well first of all he wouldn't fall for
the same things that they've said to
every american president forever
with everybody no we built the greatest
military in the world
and the better it is the less likely it
is that we're going to have to use it
but everything that we've achieved
together is on the line on june 5th
in this election you can send a message
to the fake news media and there's a lot
of them right back there
and they'll find something wrong with
this evening i don't know he may never
stop actually it's interesting he may
never stop the speech
shouted love they'll say it was a
horrible protester
they'll find something kelly and david
they're going to find something they're
looking to having a hard time
it's been a love fest this is a love
fest for these two people
june 5th guys huge
but they all want the silicon valley
censors and the corrupt democrat
political oh my god
they're partners you must vote for david
perdue and kelly lefler go out and vote
with your help we are going to continue
our mission to save america
we will defend the right to life
religious liberty free speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
they're going to take your guns away
we will always support the heroes of law
enforcement
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will preserve peace through
strength
we will protect social security and
medicare and we will always protect
patients this woman's on the phone
whoever she's talking to is like it's
not still going on is it
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students and children
and restore patriotic education to our
schools
we will teach our children to love our
country honor our history
and always respect our great
american flag
and we will live by the words of our
national model in
god we trust
will trump dance to augusta who thinks
trump dances today
and from athens to right here right here
this is a nice place
wherever the hell we are valdesta
we inherit the legacy of generations of
american patriots
who gave their blood sweat and tears to
defend our country and our freedom
we stand on the shoulders of american
heroes who crossed the oceans
settled the continent tamed the
wilderness laid down the railroads
raised up the great skyscrapers won two
world wars
defeated fascism and communism and made
america into the single greatest nation
in the history of the world and if they
get in
and add me into the group if you don't
mind
we will be greater than ever before
without question
the best is yet to come proud citizens
like you helped build this country
and together we are taking back our
country our fight to drain the
washington's
we're taking it back but he's been
president for four years and is now
leaving
we will not bend we will not break we
will not
yield we will never give in we will
never give up and we will never back
down
we will never ever surrender
yeah what is he talking about because we
are americans
and our hearts bleed red
white and blue
and i can see to joe biden good night
everybody see you in 2024
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god and
together
with the incredible people of georgia
we have made america powerful again
they've done it
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
we have made america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you georgia get out
and vote
get out and vote
all right we'll play our own music
though they didn't bother to interview a
single
witness just like you they don't want to
know the truth
well you probably know the truth okay so
so there's rudy passing gas
but the content of this was also
disgusting this went on for hours
[Music]
there it is oh that's perfectly timed oh
my god
that could not be more perfect
just like you they don't want to know
the truth
well you probably know the truth
[Music]
why don't you look at the registered
voters on there
how many registered voters are on there
[Music]
witness wow that is just amazing
well let's get that out and then i think
this one would even work as well
[Music]
big massive dumps there it is
[Applause]
oh my god it's too perfect
big massive dump
[Music]
big
[Music]
all right let's pause that okay listen
if you're heading out
please make sure if you're watching on
youtube
hit that subscribe button you'll be
notified when we go live again i really
appreciate when everybody subscribes
you can use the coupon code fresh start
for 75
off a membership at joinedpakman.com
more than 160 people already have
let's open the phones because the calls
have been a little racy lately
sometimes our entire stream will get
demonetized on youtube
because of a call we take at the end so
what i'm going to be doing is we are
going to be going twitch
exclusive for calls talk to me right now
okay davidpakman.com discord but you've
got to go to my twitch to watch the
calls live twitch.tv slash david pakman
okay
so i'm gonna pinch off the facebook and
youtube streams now
come over to twitch twitch.tv david
pakman
and then we're opening up the phone
lines very very strongly okay here we go